bonjour à tous ces gens là en prison
les noms de squeeze on avec ian butin en
doutez pas on vient pas de voir une
intro justement s'est fait mal non
[ __ ] les formes et japonais sur steve
bowles et en fait on va jouer à la balle
au prisonnier voilà le jeu auquel on
joue quand on a entre 5 et 20 45 ans du
coup pour toi avec on y joue aujourd'hui
enfin une petite partie rapide c'est
plus direct en mode histoire ça aurait
été sympa quand même
pendant l'histoire du de la balle au
prisonnier on fait partie rapide poulpe
ou l'immeuble et moi je prends tous les
je vais tous et je vais te poule à poulx
et irene ok c'est parti gelabale
comment je l'envoie et hop là ok je vais
me cacher dans l'aude à s'effacer pas
voilà aux plantes et là tu es mort aux
cons mais qu'il est un peu ko il faut le
mettre vraiment ko a des relents de
temps de yes je te l'avoué bien jouer
jérôme à je trouve qu'il ouvre un petit
peu trop pourquoi tu as dit c'était pour
l'union la ferme drouin kaboom voilà peu
partout on a trouvé un jeu où il ya un
effort est sa réelle saveur voix
l'attention la capucine comme si on
t'emmerde aux voitures
je pense que laval pas de pitié pour la
mecque allongés sur des métaux a atteint
mais c'est quoi s'acheter moitié je suis
sûr que je crains avec sa poésie je
bouge pas si tu crains [ __ ] je crée un
max était même nom du père mais on
attend on a voulu faire un test j'ai
jamais voulu faire de test un partout
yan tu arrêtes avec tarbes xiam [ __ ]
mais c'est mauvais oui et là je crois
j'ai pas compris c'est quoi super fort
je n'ai pas trop compris le but du miel
et la balle tôt personne s'appelle
jérôme jérômienne voilà à nadal a à g
ont mis à la gagner
bravo aux caisses pas se cacher des
reins veille à un crash fait dans cinq
rames de ce patron d'un crapaud rock
matte et plus longtemps au la balle est
allée
non je ne sais pas on attend qu'une
bague est retoquée au début du recul à
toi pour la science j'ai envie d'aller
les voir de toit d observer les une
telle mesure je me souviens d'un épisode
avec du miel où je voulais faire aussi
en jeu
comment anticiper les spots et il est
trop tard je te prends quand tu veux me
caler
qu'ils sachent derrière les règlements
de la caf gameplay du monde va mal et je
suis caché ben aknoun a mis ma vie c'est
comme ça qu'elle tient sa parole en
place at il ajouté choux à la crème
parce qu'enfin ce moment où watsco nato
anatomique variantes non c'est à
l'épaule ballmer weir à la seconde
également la revue des balades ne pas
parler français
oui on est déjà sur le crâne ce soir à
des fois quand tu anticipes what you're
gonna do
jérôme miel contre poule et des trousses
pasqua tuberie du mont des cats nadjar
tin tua lâcher ce match n'a pas poussé à
tituber la coutume a raté non malgré l
as que je vais rater vos corps de zéro
tu peux remonter haut au téléphone
balmont ah oui je gagne la prochaine
gagne tout terrain de basket alors là
c'est pour toi ian dyson chinoise
il ya déjà des gens tu me parles tout un
[ __ ] de tours ok toi je te pète la
gueule
déjà que soient claires entre nous
oh là là là là ce move de folie avec la
saucisse g tapoté la joue et massif on
l'a bien vu que je suis un super copains
oui je remets mon titre en jeu tout de
suite ces partis même terrain même
saucisses même jouissons ça marche pas
ça par contre il paraît que ça au [ __ ]
j'ai failli aller dessus en plus comme
un conte [ __ ] de moi une saucisse toi
tu n'as pas ta saison j'avais la société
a plus le droit de gagner au
chacun pense y avait une d'accord la
targette super la super je suis
incapable c'est ce qui va se passer
non je vais demander aux gens de
s'abonner à sa chaîne puis enlever ça a
été la mairie a recommencé loin encore
de saas et film d'horreur ça tient mais
non c'est non non non jean veil crient
au loup
et la vingtaine il n'hésitait pas à
aimer ça vous a plu allez vous abonner à
la chaîne de yann un vrai professionnel
en tout ce qui est de niamey 100% balle
au prisonnier maps taire tout le monde
comment bien esquiver les balles
anticipé anticipe est important c'est
plein de bons conseils qui vous
serviront jamais alerte réseau boscher
cet été opportun ou bien tu as deux
mondes urines
pis